>>> PARENTS OF A NEW YORK
COLLEGE STUDENT ARE DESPERATELY
PLEADING FOR HELP TO FIND THEIR
SON.
KENNY DeLAND JR. WAS STUDYING
ABROAD EASTERN FRANCE JUST
OUTSIDE LEON, AND HIS FAMILY
HASN'T HEARD FROM HIM SINCE
NOVEMBER 27th.
>> JASON CARROLL IS WITH US NOW.
SO JASON, WHAT DO YOU KNOW?
>> Reporter: YEAH.
IT'S A LOT TO UNPACK HERE.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT IS
MONITORING THE SITUATION.
KEN DeLAND'S PARENTS SAY IT IS
COMPLETELY OUT OF CHARACTER FOR
HIM NOT TO HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT.
THEY HAVE NOT HEARD FROM HIM
SINCE LAST MONTH.
WHAT WE'RE ABOUT TO SHOW YOU IS
PERHAPS THE LAST KNOWN IMAGE OF
DeLAND.
IT SHOWS HIM JUST AS HE WAS
ENTERING A SPORTING GOODS STORE
IN THE SOUTH OF FRANCE.
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THAT PICTURE
THERE, THE PREVIOUS PICTURE, HE
WAS WEARING A RED JACKET, AND A
GRAY KNIT CAP.
THAT WAS ON DECEMBER 3rd.
SO HERE'S JUST SORT OF A QUICK
RECAP OF WHAT WE KNOW AT THIS
POINT.
DeLAND IS A SENIOR AT ST. JOHN
FISHER UNIVERSITY IN ROCHESTER,
NEW YORK.
HIS FAMILY LAUNCHED A WEBSITE
DETAILING HIS LAST KNOWN
WHEREABOUTS.
THEY SAY THEY ACTUALLY HEARD
FROM HIM LAST ON NOVEMBER 27th.
THAT WAS VIA WHATSAPP.
THAT'S WHEN HE APPARENTLY
BOARDED A TRAIN, AND TWO WEEKS
LATER, THE PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE
IN THE CITY WHERE DeLAND WAS
STUDYING FRENCH, THEY HAD OPENED
AN INVESTIGATION AFTER HIS
FELLOW STUDENTS HAD REPORTED HIM
MISSING.
THEN ON NOVEMBER 30th, THERE WAS
A PING FROM HIS PHONE, AND THEN
NOTHING UNTIL HE WAS SPOTTED
AGAIN ON THE SURVEILLANCE
CAMERAS AT THAT SPORTING GOODS
STORE IN THE SOUTH OF FRANCE.
ST. JOHN FISHER UNIVERSITY SAYS
IT'S WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF FOREIGN
STUDY ON THE INVESTIGATION.
AIFS SAYING IN A STATEMENT, WE
ARE WORKING WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHO HAVE BEGUN A
SEARCH, AND WE ARE HOPING FOR
HIS SWIFT AND SAFE RETURN.
AGAIN, THE STATE DEPARTMENT IS
WORKING WITH FRENCH AUTHORITIES.
HIS COMMUNITY AND HIS FAMILY
PRAYING AT THIS POINT FOR HIS
SAFE RETURN.
BIANNA?
>> ALL RIGHT, JASON CARROLL.
THANK YOU.
>>> AND JOINING ME NOW IS KENNY
DeLAND JR.'S MOTHER, CAROL LAWS
AND HIS FATHER, KEN DeLAND SR.
IS ON THE PHONE.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING WITH
ME.
WE SAID THAT THE LAST TIME YOU
SPOKE WITH YOUR SON WAS NOVEMBER
27th.
CAROL, WHAT WITH YOU TELL ME
ABOUT THAT CONVERSATION?
>> YOU KNOW, IT WAS LIKE ANY
NORMAL CONVERSATION THAT WE HAVE
HAD.
HE'S TELLING ME ABOUT THE TIME
THAT HE'S HAVING IN EUROPE, AND
HE WAS LOOKING FORWARD TO COMING
HOME FOR CHRISTMAS, AND STARTING
TO PUT THE PLANS IN PLACE FOR
THAT.
>> AND BEFORE HE WENT SILENT
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS,
KEN -- WAS IT TYPICAL FOR THERE
TO BE LONG STRETCHES WITHOUT
HEARING FROM YOUR SON?
>> NO, I WOULD HEAR FROM HIM
FREQUENTLY.
NOT EVERY DAY MAYBE NECESSARILY,
BUT EVERY OTHER DAY AT THE VERY
LEAST WHERE HE WOULD CHECK IN
AND SEE HOW I WAS DOING, AND I
WOULD ASK HIM HOW HE WAS DOING,
AND HE ENJOYED ALL THE
INTERNATIONAL TRAVEL THAT THIS
TRIP HAD PROVIDED HIM, AND HE
TOOK LOTS OF PICTURES.
>> KEN, THE PUBLIC PROSECUTOR
THERE SAID THIS.
THE YOUNG MAN REPORTEDLY TOLD
SEVERAL PEOPLE THAT HE HAD
ARRIVED IN FRANCE UNDERPREPARED
AND WAS HAVING DIFFICULTY MAKING
FRIENDS.
DID HE TALK TO YOU ABOUT ANY
CHALLENGES HE WAS HAVING IN
FRANCE OR DO YOU THINK THAT
MIGHT HAVE ANY ROLE IN HIS
SILENCE OR DISAPPEARANCE?
>> IT'S HARD TO SAY.
WE CAN ALL SPECULATE.
I'M NOT REALLY AWARE OF, YOU
KNOW, I UNDERSTAND HE TOOK
FRENCH IN HIGH SCHOOL.
HE TRIED TO PREPARE HIMSELF FOR
THIS TRIP.
COULD YOU HAVE KNOWN FRENCH
BETTER?
YEAH.
BUT HE HAD SOME FRIENDS THAT HE
TRAVELED WITH, WITH THE TRIPS
THAT WERE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
AIFS, INCLUDING PARIS, AND HE
WENT TO LEON, AND HE WAS ON --
WHEN THERE WAS A BREAK WITH
SCHOOL, HE ALSO WENT TO ITALY,
BUT HE DID THAT ON HIS OWN, AND
I WASN'T AWARE OF HIM NOT BEING
ABLE TO MAKE FRIENDS EASILY.
SO TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION, I
WAS NOT AWARE OF THAT.
>> CAROL, WE KNOW THAT FROM THE
REPORTING THAT HE WAS WITH A
HOST FAMILY.
HAS THE HOST FAMILY BEEN ABLE TO
OFFER ANY USEFUL INFORMATION?
>> I HAVEN'T SPOKE WITH THE HOST
FAMILY.
SO TO ANSWER THAT, NOT REALLY.
I HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING FROM
THEM.
>> ARE --
>> DO AUTHORITIES -- GO AHEAD.
>> THE LEADERS THROUGH AIFS HAD
SPOKEN WITH THE HOST MOTHER, AND
FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND, HER
ENGLISH, YOU KNOW, WAS NOT SO
GOOD.
SHE WAS PREDOMINANTLY FRENCH
SPEAKING.
SO WE HAVEN'T HAD A LOT OF
CONTACT WITH THAT PERSON, AND
THERE'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF A
RESTRICTION AS TO WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO FIND OUT WITH THIS
CASE, WITH THE PRIVACY ACT IN
PLACE.
>> YEAH.
YOU SAY THERE'S BEEN A
RESTRICTION.
CAROL, I WONDER, ARE YOU
SATISFIED, CONSIDERING THE
RESTRICTIONS, WITH THE AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION THAT YOU ARE
RECEIVING FROM THE STATE
DEPARTMENT, THAT YOU ARE
RECEIVING FROM FRENCH
AUTHORITIES?
>> I FEEL LIKE I'M NOT REALLY
RECEIVING ANY INFORMATION.
>> YEAH, THAT'S --
>> IT'S BEEN VERY DIFFICULT.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE BEEN --
REALLY, SOMEONE ELSE HAS BEEN
STUCK IN THE MIDDLE TO DO THE
SPEAKING FOR US, AND IT WAS --
IT'S BEEN DIFFICULT TO GET
REALLY ANY INFORMATION BACK.
NAMES, WHO THEY ACTUALLY REALLY
SPOKE TO.
>> CAROL, HAVE AUTHORITIES THERE
IN FRANCE, HAVE THEY TOLD YOU IF
THEY BELIEVE YOUR SON IS STILL
IN FRANCE?
>> NO.
I CAN ANSWER THAT.
>> THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION
WOULD BE NO.
I'VE REACHED OUT TO THE EMBASSY
SEVERAL TIMES.
I EVEN SPOKE WITH THEM THIS
MORNING SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 4:30
A.M.
I CALLED THE EMBASSY AGAIN.
THERE'S -- THERE'S NO
RECIPROCATION OF INFORMATION.
AGAIN, THAT PRIVACY ACT PREVENTS
DISCLOSURE OF INFORMATION.
YOU CAN GIVE THEM INFORMATION,
BUT THEY CANNOT GIVE YOU
INFORMATION.
I'VE CALLED LOCAL -- THE LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND THE SAME
THING IS IN EFFECT IN THE FRENCH
POLICE DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
LOCAL TO THAT AREA IN WHICH HE
WAS LAST SEEN.
SO IT'S VERY LIMITING.
>> YEAH.
CAROL, DO YOU BELIEVE THAT YOUR
SON IS IN DANGER?
>> I WOULD LIKE TO NOT THINK SO,
BUT WHEN YOU DON'T KNOW, YOU
JUST DON'T KNOW.
I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM HIM.
>> YEAH.
KEN, ONE MORE FOR YOU.
YOU HAVE LAUNCHED THIS WEBSITE
TO GET ANY TIPS, TO GET ANY
INFORMATION.
HAVE TIPS BEEN COMING IN THROUGH
THE WEBSITE, AND ARE ANY OF
THESE TIPS, ANY OF THE
INFORMATION CREDIBLE, LEADING TO
ANY SOLID LEADS?
>> SO THERE HAS BEEN TIPS THAT
COME IN, AND I TRY TO PASS THE
TIPS ON.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY CHECK OUT
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, I'VE SENT
THEM TIPS TO -- TO MY AGENT, THE
FBI AGENT THAT I HAVE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH, AND I TRY TO
FORWARD THEM TO THE EMBASSY, AND
THEN THEY GET DISPERSED FROM
THERE.
I'M HOPING THAT INTERPOL HAS
GOTTEN INVOLVED, AND WE HAVE
BEEN INTERVIEWED BY SEVERAL NEWS
MEDIA STATIONS, YOU KNOW, AND
WE'RE HOPING WE CAN WITH YOUR
HELP, AND THE HELP OF OTHERS, WE
CAN GET THE WORD OUT THERE.
>> WELL, THE WEBSITE IS
FINDKENDeLAND.COM.
CAROL LAWS, KEN DeLAND SR.
I MEAN, WE'RE SHOWING MORE
PICTURES HERE.
OF COURSE, IF YOU HAVE ANY